are energy weapons attacking people's
brains
it sounds like science fiction but the
biden administration is facing pressures
to investigate if adversaries are using
microwave or radio weapons to attack the
brains of us diplomats
spies and military personnel sonic
attacks on government officials leading
to vertigo
pounding headaches and nausea so is this
for real the alleged energy attacks
occurred on the south side of the white
house last november
sickening a white house aid that
followed a similar incident in 2019 in a
virginia suburb reportedly injuring an
administration aide walking her dog
or is it just mass hysteria
it all started in havana cuba in late
a bunch of u.s diplomats started having
vertigo nausea and headaches and the u.s
state department investigated the issue
26 americans working in this diplomatic
community based there
have been confirmed to have been
attacked according to the state
department
with what we still don't know wow that's
some investigative work they did down
there
yes they were attacked don't know with
what but it was definitely an attack
i mean if you google vertigo nausea and
headache the first thing that comes up
is something called a
migraine but that can't be it it has to
be an attack by an enemy after all it
happened to an american diplomat in
china as well
including his ringing in her ear
phenomena
throwing up dizziness trouble
concentrating
yes none of us have ever thrown up felt
dizzy had trouble concentrating or the
rare phenomenon of ringing in your ear
so it must have been an attack
by enemy microwave or radio waves that's
the only logical explanation
16 americans posted in china were
evacuated
after reporting sounds or symptoms i
wonder how that looked
yeah hi um i'd like to report a sound
these
symptoms that these folks are
experiencing aren't
in their imagination no i'm sure the
symptoms weren't fantasy but if you have
a headache
it says a lot about you if your first
thought is that russians are behind the
headache
the russians are somehow involved aren't
they well the russians remain a primary
suspect
of course i'd be sincerely shocked if
the u.s government
didn't think russia was behind something
anything at all at this point
every time you cough it was russia isn't
it scary though that such
wild accusations are being thrown around
without any
evidence the united states government is
still not sure
who or what is responsible for those
health attacks
then how do you know their attacks when
you don't know where a supposed attack
is coming from or what
is the cause of it can you still say
it's an attack that's
literally the definition of paranoia the
biden administration could maybe work on
fixing
that health issue instead of chasing
culprits of imaginary attacks or at
least show us some proof